should you invest in bitcoins I tell
people no I tell people that the value
that people are finding bitcoins today
is definitely speculative and so that
doesn't mean you can't make a lot of
money everyone knows what's called the
greater fool theory that you make money
from greater fools and you hope you're
the lesser fool but obviously there are
just as many people who fail on that
Bettis who win on it so not necessarily
as something to invest in today but the
technology the idea this is very
interesting this is worth looking at so
what bitcoin creates is a ledger that
needs no bank and that's actually pretty
important because if you think about
what is a bank at least as far as the
the money transfer on that checking the
savings not the loan part but the you
know the financial the moving money part
of a bank it's really it's a secure
ledger there the bank does not just have
a little file that says your account is
three thousand dollars in it
they insist that when you write
something they make a note in their
ledger that one thousand dollars was
transferred from your account someone
else's account and so on and that's
important to make it secure well what
the designers of bitcoin created was a
way to make a ledger that's secure and
that everyone can trust but that no one
owns or controls and this allows people
to have money that can be free of the
influence of governments which is both
bad if you're a government and great if
you're don't like what governments do
with their monetary policies it lets the
policy be set by consensus and software
so Bitcoin basically has found a way to
always know what the majority thinks and
by always knowing what the majority
thinks you get something you you hope
you can trust in theory if someone
controlled more than half of the
computers in the world they could take
over Bitcoin but that's pretty unlikely
so why is that exciting well I grew up
with the internet and I'm old because
the Internet's actually been around for
a while
and the things that I think gave us the
revolution of the internet that that
made it change the world so much are
things like the fact that it's open and
anyone can innovate on it and things
like the fact that the smarts in the
internet are not in
network there in your phone there in the
web server you're talking to there in
your desktop computer they're not in the
networking equipment and that means that
you can innovate on the internet without
asking anyone's permission you don't
have to call the phone company and say
hey I want to put up a cool website I'm
just going to do it and that gave us all
of these wonderful things like Google
and YouTube and Facebook and all these
other websites because people sitting in
their father's basements could create
new products and send them out to the
world and try them without a MIDI ask
anyone's permission and without having
to spend a lot of money now bitcoin is
also efficient it's designed to allow
financial transactions to take place at
a very low cost but this system that
doesn't have anyone controlling it and
thus has no one to ask permission of is
a system that will allow that type of
innovation to take place in the world of
finance and in the world of contracts
the same kind of innovation that
happened in the world of communications
and interacting with other people that
the internet gave us so the hope for
Bitcoin is this is a platform where lots
of innovators all sorts of innovators
people like the people in dorm rooms who
gave us all those big Internet companies
can do the same thing in finance and in
contracts and I say and in contracts
because well the only thing people use
Bitcoin for today is effectively to
write cheques that transfer title in
some bitcoins to another person or
another secret number to count because
it's designed to be public in what you
do but private in terms of who's doing
it it actually becomes possible to do
things like a write a contract and say I
transfer one Bitcoin to you if the
following is true like if you've
delivered the thing you're supposed to
deliver to me or something like that and
so now the contracts are enforced
without courts without any other third
party so the ability for people to just
play with that and innovate with that
that's really exciting and that's why
you want to pay attention